[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Eyes on
Enterprise," where
I bring on Googlers to
talk about the technology
landscapes that are
helping enterprises scale,
adapt, and modernize.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And today I have on Collin
Frierson, security specialist
for Google Cloud.
And we're going to be
talking about cloud security
and privacy, which is a
super highly-requested topic,
so we have a lot to get through.
But Collin is here to talk
about our comprehensive security
approach, all the
work that we've
been doing over
the last 20 years,
and how you can leverage
some of those benefits.
So Colin, thanks for being here.
COLLIN FRIERSON:
Thanks for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right,
so diving straight into it,
I want to talk about
how a lot of companies
have concerns over
Cloud Security.
They're still on premise.
They're starting to migrate
some workloads that make sense.
So, are there any
major differences
in how they should
approach security
on premise versus in the cloud?
COLLIN FRIERSON: The
biggest difference
is, when you're
in the cloud, you
get to share the responsibility
of security with the provider.
So when you're on
premise, you have
to worry about everything
from provenance of hardware
all the way through what your
software is actually deployed.
When you're using
a cloud provider,
you get to share
that responsibility.
So there's a lot of
things you no longer have
to worry about,
depending on which
services you're consuming.
And that's a really good thing.
Enterprises are far
more likely to be secure
if they have less things
to worry about and offer
those responsibilities
to a provider.
STEPHANIE WONG: And of course,
a lot of the cloud technologies
have matured over the
last five to 10 years.
They still have
on-premise technology.
So can you comment on how cloud
security has also matured along
with it or how we've
been able to adapt
to those new technologies?
COLLIN FRIERSON: I think
the biggest difference
there is, because of the
size of investment cloud
has in both infrastructure
and supply chain,
cloud is able to solve a lot
of these problems fundamentally
differently than a
traditional enterprise would,
simply because of the
scale and nature of the way
you're buying.
Google, for example, has been
building our own systems,
provenance from end to end.
So we own the manufacturing
and the supply chain there.
So we get to do things from
a supply chain logistics
perspective that other
companies don't do.
They have to buy from a
traditional enterprise
vendor like Dell or HP.
And you have to trust that
vendor then implicitly
if you're buying
equipment from them.
STEPHANIE WONG: So we've
talked about the technology
and landscape a little bit.
But what about security teams?
Because obviously, people are
at the heart of a security
approach and so are the tools.
Do you think it's more
important that you
have a comprehensive
security model that
includes both people and tools?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Tools are a
great way to augment people.
But they're certainly
no substitute.
So depending on the size
of the organization,
I'd probably have
very different advice.
For the very large
organizations,
it's absolutely critical
that they invest in security.
Most of my major
Fortune 500 companies,
it's a matter of
where they invest.
So I try really hard to
make sure they're investing
in things that are effective.
For smaller companies, it's
a matter of, will you invest?
And I'm trying
really hard to say,
it is worth it to
make sure you're
investing in a security team.
Even if it's just
a couple of people,
I want them fully dedicated
and only doing security.
Because they can make
a big difference,
and they can also make great
recommendations on what tools
they need, what risk the
company is likely to face.
But you wouldn't
believe the number
of mid and small
companies that have
half of a person
dedicated to security
and just hope
nothing goes wrong.
We have a nice saying
internally here at Google.
It's hope is not a strategy.
STEPHANIE WONG: Definitely
not in securities.
COLLIN FRIERSON: No, definitely
not in security, not even
for SREs.
Hope is not a strategy.
STEPHANIE WONG: One thing that
I've also heard and talked
about with customer is
automating security practices
as much as possible-- like, for
example, building compliance
as a checkpoint in
your CIC process
before deploying,
things like that.
That probably helps to create
a more lean security team.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Absolutely.
It is critical to have
automation in place there.
A lot of times, people get
really worried when we say,
oh, we're to automate
remediations to incidents.
Because people go, well, wait.
I don't want you turning things
off or shutting them down.
I say, well, what
would an analyst
do if they saw an incident
like this in their SIEM.
Well, they'd go get
more information.
OK, how do I
automatically get you
that information so you don't
have to manually go get it?
And if you know, well,
nine times out of 10,
I take this action, how can I
just take that action for you--
except in the one out of 10.
Maybe I wake you up when
I take that exception
or when it doesn't make sense
that one time out of 10.
So reducing the total
volume of events
that analysts have to respond
to is really important.
And then trying to make
them as fast as possible
is also critical.
It's almost as important
to filter out noise.
So we know there's a lot of
security tools out there.
And analysts can spend
just as much time trying
to filter through what is a
signal but not really an event.
So automating that
process can be just as
important to make
sure that they're
spending their time on things
that are really critical.
STEPHANIE WONG: It seems
like one underlying principle
that's important
here is creating
a more proactive security
practice as opposed
to reactive in those
cases, as well.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Absolutely.
Again, as you
shift to the cloud,
your risk posture is
going to change, which
means your priorities change.
And re-evaluating
that is something
that not everybody has
very much experience in,
because enterprises are
within their first 10
years of moving to the cloud.
So re-prioritizing
what risks you're
likely to face as a business
is really important.
And then focusing your time
and energy on those things
is critical.
STEPHANIE WONG: All
right, so phishing--
I know that's been a huge
topic in the last couple
of for the start of breaches.
How do we actually categorize
how severe of a problem
this actually is?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
It's a big problem.
There's been several
high-profile breaches
in the last couple of years
that started with phishing.
And we think about 85%
of all cyber crimes
initiate via phishing.
STEPHANIE WONG: So I've
heard of these tests
that I know I've seen
in my past companies
as well, where they
send you an email
to try to test your
employees and see if you'll
give any log-in information.
Do people still use that?
Does it work?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
You'd be surprised.
Everybody still does those.
But we have not
seen great results
in terms of getting people
to be better at this.
It turns out,
about 18% of people
will fail those
exams every time.
It's just a question of
which percentage failed.
Well, while companies still
certainly do those exercises,
I'm not a big fan.
I don't think they actually
make the company any safer.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can
you talk about what
we do here at Google?
Because I know we have a
different approach to that.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Yeah.
So our approach has been the
employee cannot be relied upon
to not put their credential
into a phishing site.
So we had to build
technology to solve
the problem for the
employees to keep them safe.
So we built a technology that's
called a hardware security key.
It's based on an open
source standard called FIDO.
And we require that everyone
use these here at Google.
So whether you're an employee,
contractor, or a vendor,
you have to have one.
And it has driven our
incident rate to zero.
STEPHANIE WONG: So, what's a
bad example of someone suffering
from a phishing attack?
Have they actually lost money
from this kind of problem?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
Yeah, actually, I
worked with a hospital
whose CFO was phished.
And the phisher,
what they did was
they emailed their purchasing
department and said,
hey, I need a purchase order.
We are trying to
close a M&A deal.
Wire $80,000 to this
account really quick.
And I'd be so grateful.
Please email me if you
have any questions.
And the accounting department,
trying to be helpful, agreed.
So they did what the CFO asked,
even though it wasn't really
the CFO.
It was the phisher--
and all because he lost
access to his email.
And so $80,000 gone
just like that--
and it happened twice--
not once but twice.
STEPHANIE WONG:
At the same place?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
At the same place.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow.
COLLIN FRIERSON: And
after the second time,
they give us a call and said,
we really need help fixing this.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, this might
be a problem at this point.
COLLIN FRIERSON: This is
getting really expensive.
STEPHANIE WONG: So tying
this back to cloud,
I know that you can obviously
use this with Google Cloud.
But can a company implement this
into their production running
systems, as well?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Absolutely.
So it's an open standard.
So Google, of course, supports
it in every account we offer.
Other major cloud providers are
picking up support, as well,
in various forms.
And keys are designed
to be used many to many.
So if you have one key,
you can use it anywhere
on the web that supports it.
And the number of places
supporting is going up rapidly.
STEPHANIE WONG: We talked about
the shared responsibility model
when it comes to security.
I know a lot of
people have concerns
over moving to the cloud.
And you mentioned that
it can actually help
a company's security posture.
Can you talk more about
how it can actually help?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Typically
things, enterprises
have an entire staff of
teams just to do patching.
And as you move on
to cloud services,
many of the managed
services don't
require you to do that at all.
It's the cloud provider's
responsibility.
Great example for
Google is actually
the Heartbleed
vulnerability back in 2014--
affected everyone on the
internet, was really scary.
Google actually had a
team that discovered this.
So we found it.
We helped the Red Hat develop
a fix back at the time.
And we actually had the entire
system patched in 46 hours--
so all of Google's
infrastructure,
multiple places.
And that was a huge
deal, especially because,
when you look at the rest of
the internet, 90 days later,
still about 30% of
the internet was still
susceptible to that risk.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, it ties back
to what were saying
earlier about having
the resources, and the
network, and everything
that we have here to be able
to run through these changes
as quickly as possible.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Yeah.
Well, and Google,
again, we invest.
So we understand
that our business
is providing world-class
secure infrastructure.
So when there's a
vulnerability like that,
we have all hands on deck, and
we've trained, and gotten ready
for this.
STEPHANIE WONG: So companies
have a lot of concern
over cloud providers
potentially using their data
or their customer's data.
So what can we do to guarantee
that that doesn't happen?
COLLIN FRIERSON: It's
a common concern.
I would break it down into
three classes of things
we do to try to help.
The first one is audits.
So we go through
really rigorous audits
to demonstrate that
we're not using data
for any purposes other
than to render the service.
So specifically, it's
like ISO 27018, which
is a cloud privacy standard.
The second one is
every cloud provider
has contractual
clauses that say,
we will only use the data
to render the services
as described.
And the data belongs
to the customer.
So Google has no intellectual
property rights contractually.
One of the other things
we launched last year
was a service called
Access Transparency,
which is a technical control.
And what that allows
us to do is produce
logs any time a Google
administrator needs
to enter a customer's
tenant to perform something,
like whether it's a port
request or maintenance.
But we show technical
evidence of that every time,
and it's immutable.
We were first in industry
to do something like that.
And also available
is now a customer
can control what types of
access they're going to permit.
Maintenance is OK,
but support's not
OK for a given set
of their environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: So when we
were talking about phishing,
you mentioned the security keys.
And that's part of a larger
picture of our overall security
philosophy, something
called defense in depth.
COLLIN FRIERSON: So
the defense in depth
is how we think about
defending ourselves from really
sophisticated adversaries.
So what we do is we
think about a problem.
We build a control.
And we build it as
the best we can.
And then the next
step is once we
think it's perfect to
assume it's broken.
So let's assume this
is going to break
in a way we can't understand
or figure out yet,
and we have to build
another separate, entirely
independent control accounting
for this one is now broken.
So when we're thinking
about a problem set,
we want there to be
multiple things that
have to all fail simultaneously
in order for data
to be exposed.
So that's what we mean
by defense in depth.
STEPHANIE WONG: And that
also means, especially even
internally at Google,
we don't use a VPN,
because we have all
these layers in place
to prevent any bad
actor from being
able to access
beyond what they're
supposed to be able to access.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Right.
VPNs would be, like, a
single point of failure.
It's much better to have
10 browser tabs, which
means 10 different
encryption channels,
in order to send data
independently to each one.
STEPHANIE WONG: One of
the interesting things
that developers care
about often is being
able to have cloud governance.
So they want to be able
to work productively
in the cloud, leverage
things like Kubernetes,
and cloud native technologies.
Yet, security teams also care
about maintaining governance
and creating card
guardrails in place.
So, how can you have a
balance between both?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Yeah, this
is the practice of DevSecOps.
The basic premise is you want
to make sure that your security
team is very close
to your developers,
so they really understand
what tools they're using,
what they need to be productive,
and the security team
is not blocking them by
writing a policy that
doesn't get looked at until
someone screams loud enough.
Having security team members
close to those developers
is key, because
they'll understand
what they're blockers
are, what they
need to do to move forward,
and where they can strike
a balance between what's risky
to the company versus what's
actually going to make the
company productive, and money,
and all that fun stuff.
STEPHANIE WONG: I think,
with a lot of enterprises,
they have a lot of
organizational structures
in place already.
So how have you
seen companies be
able to restructure that
so that they can work
more closely with developers?
COLLIN FRIERSON: The
best teams I've seen
are the ones where the security
person is embedded and has
a dotted line report to
the developer's manager.
So they have the same goals.
They go to the
same team meetings.
But they also get security
saying, hey, don't let
them go off the reservation.
We still need to make sure that
the guardrails are in place
and we're following this
basic operational model.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
companies obviously want
to maximize protecting their
sensitive data on the cloud.
And they take
advantage or have heard
of things like Zero
Trust, parameter lists.
Do we employ those kind of
concepts here at Google Cloud?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
So last year, we
launched a service that lets
you build perimeters round
your APIs, which, again,
is much easier to do
than trying to manage
perimeters around IP addresses.
And we also have,
again, layering controls
on that defense
in depth strategy
to make sure that, in order
to access sensitive data,
there must be five gates
that are passed through.
But we can still check
for all of the things
that an enterprise
security team would like.
What device are you on?
Where are you coming from?
What time of day is it?
Have I seen you on
this device before--
things like that.
STEPHANIE WONG: I want to
talk a little bit about some
of the announcements we heard
at Next last year and things
like Access Transparency,
which you mentioned,
and external key management.
Do you mind going into it?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Sure.
So this is all about us
giving evidence to customers
that their data is not being
used by Google for any purposes
other than to render services.
External Key Manager is really
targeted for major enterprises.
So it's a way for them to
retain ownership of their keys
on premise while
still interacting
with Cloud Services.
It's a first in
industry, where they
have to maintain their existing
key infrastructure on prem.
But we actually get to
programmatically interact
with that system through cloud,
which means, if at any point
they decide they don't
want to use cloud anymore
and they turn off their
key services on prem,
all the cloud services
immediately stop working.
STEPHANIE WONG: We can't
talk about security
without talking
about compliance.
We know that
different industries
like banking versus health care
has different regulatory needs.
So how are we able to
meet those concerns?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
Yeah, so at Google,
we decided everyone
should have access
to secure infrastructure.
So we built Google
Cloud on top of what
we consider the most technically
sophisticated and secure
infrastructure and then
built a compliance and audit
program on top of that.
So it means, whether you're in
health care, or life sciences,
or in banking, or
even in government
in the federal space, we can
meet your regulatory needs
with the same platform.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Regulatory compliance
is obviously one way that we
instill trust in our customers.
But we also have to
meet the changing
legal needs of each country.
I'm sure those
constantly change.
So, how are we putting an
effort into adapt to those?
COLLIN FRIERSON: Yeah,
this is a huge effort.
Whether it's regulation
and rules in the US,
versus Australia, the
EU, Japan, every country
has rules about use
of data and privacy.
And Google's stance
here is offering
the most secure and
private platform
we can and, again, meeting
the regulations once we've
done that.
So in most cases,
like in the GDPR,
for example, most of the work
we had already been doing.
And it was a matter
of, well, how
do we acertain show this to
the EU regulatory bodies?
Same thing for HIPPA--
we already take data privacy
more seriously than HIPPA does.
We just need to demonstrate
that what we're doing
meets the spirit and the
technical requirements
of those rules.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now, coming
from a regulatory perspective,
how do companies actually
adapt to those changing
legal requirements,
like GDPR, CCPA, those?
COLLIN FRIERSON: The
cloud provider actually
helps quite a bit,
because they take
on some of the regulatory risk
and can help with compliance.
Although, we certainly don't do
everything for the enterprise.
The enterprises I've seen
that have been really worried
about this are very quickly
accelerating their adoption
to cloud, because they can
now share this liability
with the cloud provider.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right,
so we just talked about a lot
here with contracting and
regulatory requirements.
But bringing it back
to the larger picture,
a lot of the sophistication
of our adversaries
is constantly increasing.
And we have a lot
of tools out there
that you can leverage to
protect your environment.
What can you say to
an enterprise that
just simply wants to keep
up with that dangerous world
out there?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
Yeah, the big one
is, get the cloud provider
to help you with as much
as you can take on.
Most enterprises' core business
is not security and technology.
So if that sounds like you, make
the cloud provider do as much
of it for you as you can.
And then try to reduce
the number of tasks
that you as an enterprise
are responsible for.
So make the cloud
provider encrypt for you.
Make the cloud provider
provide systems
that our GDPR
compliant, so you can
write policies that are easier
to enforce, rather than have
to enforce systems, too.
STEPHANIE WONG: So, what
can a company actually
do today so that they can
start improving their security
posture?
Or those who are already
bringing on Google Cloud, what
can they do to start
leveraging some of the tools
that you've mentioned?
COLLIN FRIERSON:
For cloud customers,
the thing I would recommend
is log into Security Command
Center.
And start going through what
tools we have available there.
It's a great way
to look at, gosh,
did I misconfigure something?
Do I have environments that
have a known exploit that's
currently active?
And we provide a lot
of those signals out
of the box in the platform.
So start there.
It's a great way
to start triaging.
And also, take a look
at our security blog.
So we publish periodically.
What are some of the best
practice for enterprises there
and how to mitigate
certain threats.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
thank you so much.
We covered a ton.
So I appreciate you
being on the show.
COLLIN FRIERSON: Thank
you for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: So everyone,
if you have any stories
or anecdotes about your
own security challenges,
how you've been able
to address them,
or if you've been
able to use some
of the tools we
talked about today,
let us know in the comments.
Take care.
And join us next time
for "Eyes on Enterprise."
[MUSIC PLAYING]